all right joining us now he is the host
of the upcoming Fox News show life
liberty and Levin nationally syndicated
radio talk show it's also a host on CR
TV the I call them the great one thank
me god bless us
look I don't want to waste a lot of time
we now have two dossiers we now have two
memos with the new memo from from
Grassley's committee tonight
and this one now talks about Sid
Blumenthal and other clintonites
literally feeding steal more phony
information and and rationalizing this
phony Russian paid-for dossier that is
number one used first to manipulate and
lie to the American people and then used
as a basis in part for a FISA warrant
against the candidate and then an
incoming president to undermine his
presidency great one I hope I couldn't
write a novel this bad and this is bad
and let me tell you couple of things
here now we know why shift and the rest
of them are fighting so hard now we know
why the left-wing Praetorian Guard
Democrat media are fighting so hard
trashing Nunez me you and others let's
walk through this quickly who are they
trying to protect Hillary Clinton Sean
who else are they trying to protect
Barack Obama his name never comes up so
let me help everybody with this Loretta
Lynch knew about these fighter warrants
Yates the Deputy Attorney General the
extensions Rob Rosenstein now the Deputy
Attorney General he knew FBI director
Comey deputy director McCabe struck the
head of counterintelligence page his
girlfriend who else would have known
about these these FISA applications and
warrants well let me tell you a little
secret
these are counterintelligence efforts
you have to assume the National Security
Council in the White House knew why
would the FBI the Justice Department
keep that from the National Security
Director in the White House why would
they keep it from the deputy director in
the White House so why would it be left
out of the president's daily
intelligence briefing which I mentioned
in March Congress also needs to get a
hold of
I am telling you where we're looking at
the FBI we're looking at the Department
of Justice and we're not looking at all
at all at the White House Hillary
Clinton paid for a warrant that's the
easiest way we can put it Hillary
Clinton colluded with the with the
Russians but it appears the FBI at the
senior-most levels colluded with the
Russians to whether it was winning or
unwitting it doesn't matter that's a
fact so the senior level of the FBI
tried to interfere with this election as
well this is why it's such a big deal
now I know Republicans are bending over
backwards saying this has nothing to do
a Muller it has everything to do a
Muller because a transition from a
counterintelligence investigation into a
criminal investigation
if the Comey of all things confesses to
being a leaker and Muller Muller's the
former FBI director those are his people
that's his environment he's not out
there as some independent force but I
want to get back to Barack Obama
it's his FBI his Department of Justice
his State Department his candidate
I cannot believe for a minute that the
National Security Council didn't know
about this and to show you how elaborate
this is now that more informations
coming out we haven't even gotten to the
incidental collection of intelligence on
people including by the way sessions
when he met with and spoke to the
Russian ambassador Michael Flynn when he
spoke to the Russian ambassador the
unmasking and leaking of his name the
record number of unmasking of American
citizens and Trump world and so forth
and so on and the American people have
been subjected to a massive propaganda
and misinformation campaign by the
Clinton campaign by the Obama
administration let me ask you a logical
question Sean why would the Russians
want Donald Trump to be President of the
United States where they get everything
they want from Hillary Clinton whether
its uranium whether it's undermining our
defense by cutting up military spending
by refusing to secure our border why in
the world would the Russians want Trump
as opposed to Hillary jumpin for a
second so really if we were able to get
the FISA application we don't wanting to
get rid of sore
methods and we were able to make public
Barack Obama's presidential daily
briefing you're betting and I agree with
you tonight that it would clearly show
that he knew all of this was happening
look they have these front guys Brennan
out there and clapper out there and
they're they're propagandists out there
but they don't have Susan Rice out there
and Ben Rhodes out there and Valerie
Jarrett out there Barack Obama has gone
into the witness protection program
nobody even knows where he is anymore
his name never comes up I'm telling you
that the frenzied defense of what's
taking place here it's to protect
Hillary and to protect Obama since when
has the Democrat Party supported law
enforcement they undermine the Baltimore
Police Department they undermined the
Ferguson Police Department the NYPD the
LAPD all of a sudden they're defending
the FBI and then they turn around and
say why are you attacking the FBI you
and I and others are defending the FBI
against the rogue activity that's taken
place at the most senior levels and the
leaking the leaking we already know
Comey zaleka McCabe's a leaker strokes a
leaker pages a leaker how many other
leakers were coming out of the FBI which
is how we knew on March 2nd 5th and 6th
of last year something was wrong we got
a little bit of FISA information being
leaked we got a little bit of stuff out
of the FBI about why excuse me the New
York Times about wiretaps we were able
to try and piece this together on your
show among others and then it all now
makes sense this is a massive spectacle
a massive Vegas can tear up ssin in the
history of this country you're a
historian well whether it is or not I
mean the fact that I because it is
listen not only do we need a special
counsel we need a commission I was
talking to my wife about this Friday
night Dersch what's mention it over the
weekend he's right we need the criminal
investigation and we need a policy
investigation to come up with what we
need to do we cannot walk away from this
all right by the way the great one will
be on this show every other week you
promised and the great one show starts
in febrile